so I'm pretty sure that I'm not the only
one in this room cut some points have
fun myself you know looking up towards
the Stars and wondered you know are we
it or are there other living planets out
there such as our own I guess it is
possible that and then the only person
who has obsessed enough about that
question to make it my career but moving
on so how do we how do we get to this
question well I would argue the first
thing to do is to turn our eyes back
down from the sky to our own planet the
earth and think about just how lucky did
the earth have to be to be the Living
Planet it is well it had to be at least
somewhat lucky had we been sitting
closer to the Sun or a bit further away
any water that we have had would have
boiled off or frozen over and it's not a
given that the planets has water on it
so had we be in a dry planet there would
not have been a lot of life on it and
even if I had had all the water that you
know we have today if that water had not
been accompanied by the kind of right
kind of chemicals to get life going we
would have in a West planet but just as
dead so it's so many things that can go
wrong what are the chances that they go
right what are the chances that the
planet forms reduce the basic
ingredients needed to to have an
audience of life happening well let's
explore that together so if you're going
to have a living planet you know the
first thing you're gonna need is a
planet but not any planet will do you're
probably gonna need a rather specific
and earth-like planets a planet that is
rocky but you can have both oceans and
land and it's sitting neither too close
not too far away from its star but I did
just right temperature and it's just
right for liquid
that is so how many of these planets do
we have in our galaxy well one of the
great discoveries of the past decades is
that planets are incredibly common
almost every star has a planet around
them some have many and among these
planets on the order of a few percents
are earth-like enough that we would
consider them potentially living planets
so having the right kanna planet it's
actually not that difficult when we
consider that there's about a hundred
billion stars in our galaxy so it gives
you about the billion potential you know
living planets but it's not enough to
just be at the right temperature or how
to write a royal composition you also
need the right chemicals and about the
second and important ingredient to make
a living planet is I think it's pretty
intuitive its water after all we did
define our planet as being potentially
living if it had the right temperature
to keep water liquids and I mean here on
earth life is water-based but more
generally water is just really good as a
meeting place for chemicals it is a very
special liquid so this is our second
ingredient their second basic ingredient
now the third ingredient I think it's
probably a little bit more surprising we
are going to need some organics in there
right since we are thinking about
organic life but organic molecule that
seems to be at the center of the
chemical networks that can produce
biomolecules is hydrogen cyanide so for
those of you who know what this molecule
is like you know it's something that's
good idea to stay away from but it turns
out that what's really really bad for
advanced life forms such as yourselves
is really really good to get the
chemistry started the right kind of
chemistry that can lead to origins of
life so now we have our three
ingredients that we need you know the
temperate planets water and hydrogen
cyanide so how often do these three come
together
how many temperate planets are there out
there that have water and hide
cyanide well in an ideal world we would
not turn one of our telescopes towards
one of these temperate planets and check
for ourselves just do these planets have
water and a cyanides on them
unfortunately we don't yet have large
enough telescopes to do this we can
detect molecules in the atmospheres of
some planets but these are large planets
sitting often pretty close to their star
nothing like these you know just right
planets that we're talking about here
which are much smaller and further away
so we have to come up with another way
and other way that we have conceived of
and then followed is to instead of
looking for these molecules in the
planets when they exist is to look for
them in the material that's forming new
planets so planets form in discs of dust
and gas around young stars and these
discs get their material from the
interstellar medium turns out that the
empty space you see between stars when
you're looking at towards them asking
existential questions it's not as empty
as it seems but actually full of gas and
dust which can you know come together in
clouds then collapses to form these
disks stars and planets and one of the
things we always see when we do look at
these clouds is water I mean I think
we're a tendency to think about water or
something that's you know special to us
water is one of the most abundant
molecules in the universe including in
these clouds this darn planet forming
clouds and not only that water is also a
pretty robust molecules actually not
that easy to destroy so a lot of this
water that is an interstellar medium
will survive the rudder dangerous
collapse journey from clouds to this to
planets so water is all right that that
second ingredient is not going to be a
problem
most planets are going to form with some
access to water so what about hydrogen
cyanide well we also see cyanides and
other similar organic molecules in these
interstellar cloud
but here we're less certain about the
molecules surviving at going from the
cloud to the disk they're just a bit
more delicate bit more fragile so if
we're going to know that this hydrogen
cyanide is sitting in the vicinity of
new planets forming we really need to
see it in the disk itself in these
planet-forming disks so about the decade
ago I started a program to look for this
hydrogen cyanide and other molecules in
these planet-forming disks and this is
what we found so good news in these six
images those bright pixels represent
emission originating from hydrogen
cyanide in planet-forming disks hundreds
of light-years away that have made it to
our telescope onto the detector and then
allowing allowing us to see it like this
so the very good news is that this disk
do you indeed have hydrogen cyanide in
them that lost more elusive ingredients
now the bad news is that we don't know
where in the discus if you look at these
I mean no one can say there are
beautiful images even even at the time
when we got them you see the pixel size
is pretty big and it's actually bigger
than these discs themselves so each
pixel here represents something that's
much bigger than our solar system and
that means that we don't know where in
the distal hydrogen cyanide is coming
from and that's the problem because
these temperate planets they can't
access hydron cyanide just anywhere but
it must be fairly close to where they
assemble for them to have access to it
so to bring this home let's think about
an analogous example that is of Cyprus
growing in the United States let's say
hypothetically that you've returned from
from Europe we have seen beautiful
Italian cypresses and you won't
understand you know it doesn't make
sense to important to the United States
could you grow them here so you talk to
the cyphers experts they tell you that
there is indeed
not too hot not too cold across the
United States we could grow them and if
you have a nice high resolution map or
image like this it's quite easy to see
that this Cyprus strip overlaps with a
lot of green fertile land pixels even if
I start degrading this math quite a bit
making it lower and lower resolution
it's still possible to tell that there's
gonna be some fertile land overlapping
with this strip but what about if the
the whole United States is incorporated
into a single pixel if the resolution is
that low what do you do now okay how do
you now tell whether you can grow
cypresses in the United States well the
answer is you can't I mean there's
definitely some fertile land there or
you wouldn't have that green tint to the
pixel but there's just no way of telling
whether any of that green is in the
right place and that is exactly the
problem we were facing what our single
pixel images of these discs but now in
hydron cyanide so what we need is
something analogous to teach those low
resolution maps that I just showed you
to be able to tell whether is overlap
between where DeHaan and cyanide is and
where these planets can access it as
they are forming so coming to the rescue
a few years ago is this new amazing
beautiful telescope Alma the Atacama
Large millimeter/submillimeter Array in
northern Chile so all my is amazing in
many different ways but the the one that
I'm going to focus on is it as you can
see I call this one telescope but you
can see there actually many dishes in
this image and this is a telescope that
consists of 66 individual dishes that
all work in unison and that means that
you have a telescope that is the size of
the largest distance you can put these
dishes away from one another which in
Alma's case is a few are a few miles so
you have a mile size in a morning mile
sized telescope and when you're such a
big telescope you can zoom in on really
small things including making maps of
hydrogen cyanide in this
forming disks so when Alma came online a
few years ago there was thunder first
things that I proposed that we use it
for and what does a map of hydrogen
cyanide look like in a disk is the
hydrogen cyanide at the right place and
the answer is it is so this is an app
sure you see the hydrent cyanide
emission being spread out across the
disk first of all it's almost everywhere
which is very good news but you have a
lot of extra bright emission coming from
close to the star towards the center of
the disk and this is exactly where we
want to see it and this is close to
where these plants are forming and this
is not what you see just first one disc
here are three more examples you can see
they all show the same thing lots of
bright hydrogen cyanide emission coming
from close to the center of the star for
full disclosure we don't always see this
there are discs where we see the
opposite where there's actually a hole
in the emission towards the center you
know this is the opposite what we want
to see you right this is not places
where we could be certain there's any
hydrogen hydrogen cyanide around where
these planets are forming but in most
cases we just don't detect hydrogen
cyanide but we detect it in the right
place so what does all this mean well I
told you're in the beginning you know
that we have lots of these temperate
planets maybe billion or so of them that
could have life develop on them if they
have the right ingredients and I've also
shown that we think a lot of time the
right ingredients are there right we
have water we have hydrogen cyanide
there will be other organic molecules as
well coming with with the cyanides this
means that planets were the most basic
ingredients for life are likely to be
incredibly common in our galaxy and if
all it takes for life to develop is to
have these basic ingredients available
there should be a lot of living planets
out there but that is of course a big s
and I would say the challenge of the
next decades for both astronomy and
chemistry is to figure out just how
often we go from having a potentially
living
having an actually living one thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]